and i got to work when i try
visuals because of a
college research project and i started to
realize how complex their challenges were
my country and novel and on
his mobile I want something that'll
Treat Me well and the name That's when  i
met people is working on the
app that uses your
cell phone camera to detect objects and
obstacles in your environment it tells
you what it sees aloud and how you
can watch tuesday melba if it is a ship
in the White Walker Red
a Western  countries so I find what I
Love Rock we started to use Google
midi to talk by video
often and talk about how
we could turn our idea
into reality thanks
to the rap music illustration Of National
Forest of gold love I wanna get rid of
stickers and  another network puts everything together and
a complete sentence goddess Coffee table
Talk Intelbras Twin fun with that we
were Used for Indoor and Outdoor
navigation and I don't let Friends for
Live Your Life and High we want to
continue using technology to
help create a more accessible world.